i think it's going to have a few things
to say here lara trump the trump 2020
campaign senior advisor
and a now a fox news contributor laura
great to see you
thanks tammy great to be back with you
look it is
very clear what you say they know
they're losing on the left and i'll tell
you how you know
they act like my three-year-old throwing
a temper tantrum whenever they don't get
their way whenever you don't have any
other answers you panic
and you divert to i don't know donald
trump put his pants on backwards which
was the most ridiculous
story of the week that i heard um but i
think you're right i think americans
every single day are waking up
because they're so sick of it they are
sick tammy
of this woke crowd who acts morally
superior and then trashes
our country they are sick of being lied
to by the folks in the white house and
in the mainstream media
they are sick of being labeled
everything under the sun
that is not a true label for them just
because they don't go along
with what the media and what hollywood
and what those on the radical left
say they should but here's the good news
is you're right we don't need to be on
defense we are on offense because i
truly believe
there are more of us than there are of
them and when we stand up and stand
together
this country is the greatest idea ever
realized there is nothing
that we cannot do we put a man on the
moon
we won world wars we developed in record
time a vaccine to end a pandemic
we will get through this nonsense but it
is going to take
americans standing up tammy and saying
enough is enough i'm so happy
and i just think it's happening they're
speaking out about what's happening
doing it every day you're right yeah
and here's here's here's what i'd i'd
suggest as well is that
when when the democrats for in 2020
presented joe biden as this moderate
normal person that tells you that the
democrats knew
what it was that americans wanted and
expected and then once the election
happened
it was just like forget it you're right
we you know we tricked you
it's like charlie brown and lucy in the
football uh doing it over and over and
over again
uh that they tricked us and like too bad
because the the
problem is nothing that they do really
is about the american people
we are like some you know shadow in the
corner
and yet they have to pander sometimes
and i have to say for you and your
family
the reason americans now are able to
step up and stand up to it
is because we've seen the example of
your father-in-law
we've seen the example of your family uh
i mean it is
role modeling is incredibly important
you don't back down
there is optimism we've seen what real
leadership can do
is there a burden to the fact that you
guys know that you remain
that symbol for americans that we can do
this
and that we can do it as happy warriors
well that's so nice of you to say and
look we wear that badge very proudly uh
you know when they're attacking you
you're doing something right because
they don't want people to hear from you
they don't want people to be inspired by
by donald trump
uh you know by people like him who who
obviously are the way forward in this
country
clearly but literally i can tell you
yeah yeah
i can tell you that that our family is
proud to take it
there's almost nothing else they can do
to us tammy so at this point
look we we can tell you there is a light
at the end of the tunnel they'll start
to run out of things i guess to say
about you at a certain point
um but it is it's something we're very
proud of i think my father-in-law was
made for this time
he was made to lead this country and
it's been an honor to support him and
and thank you it's an honor to see you
thank you again for continuing on laura
trump appreciate you being here tonight
great job
and now hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else